[Musique]
bonsoir à tous lundi 4 novembre le début
d'une nouvelle semaine d'information
locale sur tv 78 bienvenue dans cette
édition
tout de suite les titres de l'actualité
locale affrontements avec les forces de
l'ordre et incendies du chapiteau de
l'arche ont tous les lignes a été le
théâtre de violences urbaines ce
week-end aujourd'hui le département des
yvelines a annoncé qu'il prendrait en
charge l'intégralité de la
reconstruction du chapiteau le
déplacement dans les yvelines de la
secrétaire d'état auprès de la ministre
de la transition écologique et solidaire
brune poirson était ce matin à carrières
sous poissy
là où une mère des déchets a vu le jour
depuis 2016 une décharge sauvage de 40
hectares qui inquiète habitants et
associations
et puis le sport ne s'est pas arrêté en
ce week-end de la toussaint handball
rugby football les principaux résultats
à suivre
à la fin de ce journal et nous aurons
également deux invités en plateau
décryptage de la réforme de l'assurance
chômage entrée en vigueur au 1er
novembre avec l'association solidarités
nouvelles face au chômage et nous
recevrons également sacha coiffeur
yvelinois qui a publié récemment dans un
livre 46 ans à d'anecdotes sur son
métier
[Musique]
mais direction tout de suite
chanteloup-les-vignes moins de 48 heures
après l incendie qui a ravagé le
chapiteau de la compagnie des contraire
le président du conseil départemental
pierre bédier s'est rendu sur place ce
midi est le département qui va financer
l'intégralité et de la reconstruction de
ce lieu culturel
au rayon ce même s'il tient encore de
beaux le chapiteau de la compagnie des
contraire n'est pas au mieux de sa forme
dans la nuit du 2 au 3 novembre ce lieu
culturel situé dans le quartier de la
noé à chanteloup les vignes a été la
cible d'un incendie criminel sous les
yeux des habitants
j'étais apeuré fin ça m'a vraiment
attristé de voir un centre culturel
comme ça brûle et à cause des changes
entre policiers et j'avais de quartier
inaugurée l'an dernier large propose aux
jeunes de s'initier aux arts du cirque
et de la danse
un espace culturel qui accueille
également des spectacles
la perte matérielle se chiffre à plus
d'un million d'euros qui a tout le
matériel qui est nécessaire au cirque et
c'est un matériel qui coûterait très
cher des installations extrêmement
importantes
ça va falloir le chiffre il ya tout le
matériel qui servait aussi à au
spectacle parce que c'était aussi un
lieu de spectacle c'était un lieu d'art
sous toutes les formes
ce chapiteau est géré par l'association
la compagnie des contraires présente
depuis près de 30 ans dans la ville le
département des yvelines a décidé de
prendre en charge l'intégralité de la
reconstruction de la structure
lorsque ces cités populaires sont
confrontés à cet océan de connerie j'ai
fini par dire mon mot eh bien nous
serons là
aux côtés des maires mais quel qu'il
soit on va reconduire le même le même
voilà donc c'est pas compliqué on a les
plans il suffit de reprendre on refait
un appel d'offres jeu il faudra
d'ailleurs qu'on voit si il est même
possible de faire un appel d'offres
restreint enfin il faut aller vite dans
moins de nom doit inaugurer ce bâtiment
sa relance le sourire sa relance
l'espoir et je pense que dès lors au
moment où la population va entendre ça
aussi les élèves et tous les enfants qui
viennent si l'espoir va réveiller en
plus de la reconstruction du chapiteau
les départements des yvelines va allouer
une aide exceptionnelle à la ville de
chanteloup les vignes pour notamment
renforcer ses équipes de sécurité et de
médiation outre le chapiteau de l'arche
pompiers et policiers ont été également
pris pour cible
ce week-end à assen sont les billes à
des affrontements samedi faisant deux
blessés mais également la nuit dernière
le premier ministre edward filet pas à
condamner fermement ces attaques elle
lors d'un déplacement aujourd'hui en
seine saint denis du côté des forces de
l'ordre c'est l'inquiétude qui prime
avec des violences qui se multiplient
dans les villes ces dernières semaines
là on a affaire à de véritable
guet-apens qui sont préparés prémédité
donc les individus effectivement le
scénario se répète un noeud attire les
pompiers mes collègues et là à ce moment
là des dizaines d'individus armés de
cailloux de mortier et parfois de
cocktails molotov effectivement attaque
mes collègues de manière complètement
coordonnées chanteloup-les-vignes n'est
pas l'épicentre du phénomène
malheureusement tout le département a
touché que savoir que lors de la soirée
d'halloween
il ya quinze communes du département qui
ont été victimes d'actes de violences
urbaines
on a pu dénombrer plus d'une
cinquantaine de poubelles brûlées est
quasiment une vingtaine d' attaques
contre les forces de l'ordre et les
pompiers
donc le phénomène se généralise sur le
département
deux personnes sont en garde à vue dont
un mineur deux enquêtes sont ouvertes
l'une confiée à la sûreté départementale
des yvelines et l'autre commissariat de
conflans-sainte-honorine afin
d'identifier l'ensemble des émeutiers et
incendiaires l autre actualité du jour
c'est cette visite celle de brune
poirson à carrières sous poissy la
secrétaire d'état auprès du ministre de
la transition écologique et solidaire à
s'est rendu sur le lieu de la décharge
sauvage un déplacement alors que le
projet de loi sur l'économie circulaire
doit être examinée avant la fin d'année
à l'assemblée nationale après une
adoption en première lecture au sénat
il comprend un volet justement sur les
dépôts sauvages sur place à la
mi-journée
patrick jacques de dixmude et manou
varaldo c'est une mer de déchets que
vous voyez derrière moi plusieurs tonnes
de détritus divers se sont amoncelées
crescendo depuis dix ans sur cette
plaine maraîchère pneus gravats de
chantier issus du bâtiment pièces
détachées chaussures oursons la nature
de ces déchets est diverse et représente
38 mille tonnes
mais
vous avez vu la carte tout à l'heure on
voit que nous avons des bouts de
décharge un petit peu disséminés sur un
ensemble de territoires énorme et qui
aujourd'hui pose de vraies difficultés à
la fois bien évidemment de dépollution
et de nettoyage mais également en amont
comment faire pour que ce type de chose
ne se reproduise plus du tout sur nos
territoires
présente partout sur le territoire les
décharges sauvages sont un véritable
fléau qui coûte entre 340 et 420
millions d'euros par an aux
collectivités brune poirson secrétaire
d'état auprès de la ministre de la
transition écologique et solidaire est
venu apporter ses solutions la lutte
contre les décharges sauvages est un des
piliers du projet de loi anti gaspillage
pour une économie circulaire c'est la
reprise gratuite des déchets qui auront
été triés au préalable parce
qu'aujourd'hui vous savez beaucoup
d'artisans par exemple ils doivent s'ils
veulent aller déposer leurs déchets dans
une déchetterie doivent payer pour ça
donc son affaire c'est que ce soit
gratuit donc pour eux ce soit facile
plus facile d'y aller on veut que la
filière pollueur payeur finance la mise
en place d'un maillage très dense de
déchèteries professionnelles partout en
france
d'autre part nous allons créer un régime
spécial de sanctions sur pour permettre
données pour permettre de donner au
maire ceux qui sont au contact
malheureusement et on l'a vu avec le
drame du décès du maire de signes cet
été pour ceux qui s'occupent eux qui
sont en première ligne et les moyens
véritablement de s'attaquer
immédiatement à ceux qui commettent ces
actes illégaux et insupportable pendant
ce déplacement des associations sont
venus faire part de leur inquiétude
parmi elles l'association rives de seine
nature environnement dont nous indique
que la lisa sion va évoluer très bien si
elle se durcit mais il faut aussi les
tribunaux appliquent la réglementation
aujourd'hui je rappelle quand même
qu'une entreprise qui déversent des
déchets sur ainsi que monsieur carasso
kouassi s'expose à 75000 euros damende
deux ans de prison et la saisie du
véhicule fait le tour de tous les
distribuer notre france et vous verrez
que cette ascension n'a jamais été
appliquée huit cent mille euros c'est le
montant que l'état versera pour ce
nettoyage d'un coût total de 3 millions
d'euros
la secrétaire d'état qui a poursuivi sa
visite cet après midi dont les yvelines
brune poirson s'est rendu dans les
locaux de nouvelles attitudes une
entreprise d'un cerf
conventionnée par l'état et par pôle
emploi elle est située à buc dans
l'actualité également ce changement
depuis le 1er janvier les premières
mesures de la réforme de l'assurance
chômage sont entrées en vigueur on va
décrypter et prendre l avis d'une
association qui travaille justement sur
cette question elisabeth aigueperse
bonsoir vous êtes bénévole et
administratives de solidarités nouvelles
face au chômage sur l'antenne de la
vallée de chevreuse justement pour
commencer qu'est-ce que sncf c'est une
association nationale qui a été créée en
1985 pour lutter contre le chômage et
soutenir les chercheurs d'emploi grâce à
des citoyens engagés tout simplement
nous avons trois axes à trépied très
rapidement l'accompagnement des
chercheurs d'emploi dans leur recherche
de projets professionnels et de
recherche d'emploi et c'est un
accompagnement évidemment qui est
gratuit personnalisé et humain qui est
surtout basé sur l'écouté mais pas que
sur les coûts également à la
méthodologie également nous créons des
emplois solidaires que nous finançons
nous mêmes
et puis nous portons la parole des
chercheurs d'emploi c'est l'objet de
notre rendez vous de ce soir
alors dans les grandes lignes sur ce qui
est entrée en vigueur au 1er novembre va
on va faire le détail avec vous
durcissement des conditions d'accès à
l'assurance chômage il faut avoir
travaillé six des 24 derniers mois pour
ouvrir des droits avancé t 4 sur les 28
derniers mois un mois de travail ne
suffit plus ne suffit plus pour
recharger ses droits désormais le délai
est allongée à six mois pour les hauts
salaires soit plus de 4500 euros brut
par mois dégressivité de la location de
30% au bout de six mois non travaillées
enfin à l'assurance chômage et élargi
aux personnes démissionnaire et aux
indépendants mais sous de strictes
conditions on peut parler de changements
profonds sur l'assurance chômage
oui très très profond c'est dire qu'on
s'est porté aujourd'hui le
le poids de l'assurance chômage sur les
chercheurs d'emploi le problème c'est
que ça précarisent les plus précaires
cirque avant on parle entre autres des
personnes qui ont des kings des clients
qui enchaîne les cdd
il avait il suffisait d'avoir un mois de
travail pendant la période pour pouvoir
recharger des droits aujourd'hui il faut
avoir travaillé six mois sur la période
et vous avez des personnes c'est pas
qu'elles ne veulent pas travailler moi
j'en connais pas qui ne veulent pas
travailler ce sont des personnes qui ont
des difficultés à travailler pour des
tonnes de raisons vous avez la fracture
numérique aujourd'hui on cherche du
travail uniquement par internet et des
personnes qui savent pas bien faire ça
donc c'est compliqué de trouver des
contrats
il ya des personnes qui sortent de
l'entreprise qui sont dans une
entreprise depuis dix ou quinze ans elle
se retrouve à faire des cv mais elles
savent plus comment faire insérer donc
toutes ces personnes là se trouve
complètement démunis et on rajoute de la
précarité à la précarité et de l'
angoisse à l'angoissé de se retrouver
sans revenu vous parle de durcissement
dans plusieurs médias vous êtes sur le
même avis bien sûr oui je pense que là
dessus tout les toutes les parties sont
vraiment unanimes c'est un durcissement
cette cette loi elle est faite pour
faire des économies mais pourquoi faire
porter aux chercheurs d'emploi ces
économies on précise que les personnes
de 53 ans de 53 ans et plus il faut
avoir pour ces personnes travaillent au
moins six mois alors sur les 36 derniers
mois le délai est allongé pour
bénéficier de l'assurance chômage on
comprend qu'on quand même le travail des
personnes plus âgées
oui alors la difficulté c'est que pôle
emploi estime que vous êtes seniors
j'allais dire à 53 ans mais les
recruteurs et le monde du travail et
tout ce que l'on entend si vous êtes
seniors à 45 ans donc vous imaginez une
personne une personne de 50 ans qui se
retrouve dans cette situation là elle a
du mal à se faire réembaucher donc
peut-être que il aurait mieux fallu
mettre en place de l'accompagnement un
essai ce que l'on demande de
l'accompagnement renforcé pour tous
plutôt que d'avoir des sanctions
financières
alors quelque chose peut-être de positif
c'est l'ouverture de l'allocation
chômage au démissionnaire et
indépendant mais avec des conditions ça
c'est la contrepartie qui sont très
strictes elles sont extrêmement strictes
et d'ailleurs les budgets et demi sur
ces deux dispositifs sont moindres par
rapport aux économies qui sont faites
pour les personnes qui sont
démissionnaires faut quand même savoir
que pour avoir éventuellement 7 droit à
cette allocation
vous devez présenter un projet au moins
6 mois al avance s'y prendre vraiment
longtemps à l avance et en plus de ça
vous devez passer dans une ancienneté
dans ce dossier et vous devez présenter
votre dossier à une commission
donc comment il fait cette commission
avec quoi comment enfin c'est un
véritable parcours du combattant pour
l'obtenir oui oui je pense qu'on va
continuer à voir beaucoup de ruptures
conventionnelles sans mise en place de
projets avant on l'a compris a un avis
très contrastés sur sur la réforme dans
la réflexion de la réforme est ce que
les des associations comme sncs que des
demandeurs d'emploi ont été associés à
cette réflexion
alors ça c'est une véritable
problématique malheureusement les
chercheurs d'emploi n'ont pas été
consultés et pourtant ça les concerne
directement
nous aurions aimé qu'effectivement on
prenne leur douleur leur avis et c'est
pour ça qu'on a lancé avec différents
partenaires sociaux une grande
consultation sur une plateforme qui
s'appelle snc expression avec un s point
fr où chaque chercheur d'emploi va
pouvoir aller s'exprimer sur les impacts
de cette réforme est également sur ce
qu'ils vivent au quotidien avec dont
plusieurs partenaires justement
qu'est-ce qu'il faut remplir sur sur ce
site on voit l'animation voilà le site
internet et toutes les informations pour
six rondes qu'est-ce qu'il faut
renseigner sur le site
ils sont simplement renseignés ses
cordes face et coordonnées nom ça reste
anonyme un bien évidemment simplement
aller témoigner
c'est assez simple et c'est très très
très ludiques comme fonctionnement et
cela va servir à quoi après justement
allons faire une restitution bien
évidemment dans un premier temps des
impacts qui sera diffusée dans notre
plaidoyer bien évidemment et puis dans
un second temps nous ferons une deuxième
une deuxième
enquête voilà une deuxième phase avec
tout ce qui change aussi au 1er avril
puisqu'il va y avoir encore beaucoup de
changements au 1er avril
plus que d'autres volets de la réforme
vont entrer en vigueur au 1er avril
et là encore ça va être très compliqué
merci elizabeth être perse d'être venu
sur ce plateau elle rappelle que vous
êtes bénévole et administratrice de
solidarités nouvelles face au chômage
sur l'antenne de la vallée de chevreuse
et on retrouve bien sûr un toutes les
informations sur cette association sur
son site internet
merci beaucoup merci en ce week-end de
la toussaint la tradition voulait que
l'on vienne fleurir les tombes de nos
proches disparus deux saisons et et
robuste pour l'hiver les chrysanthèmes
sont traditionnellement prisé mais
d'autres fleurs ont pu être choisi ce
week-end reportage à montigny le
bretonneux de marylène iapichino les
chrysanthèmes à pomponnettes la star des
cimetières du mois de novembre
coloré et robuste c'est ce qui se vend
le plus pour fleurir les tombes à la
toussaint maryvonne et son mari ne se
sont pas trompés s'est porté sur ces
quatre magnifiques m 4 j'ai choisi des
chrysanthèmes ben voyons avec les
couleurs qui me plaisait avec des
boutons pour que ça puisse durer plus
longtemps possible puisque effectivement
on ne passe de façon tout à fait
ponctuel sur les tombes et que c'est
bien de faire poursuivre notre présence
et l'affection qu'on a pour les êtres
qui nous ont quittés de façon prolongée
des chrysanthèmes sont locaux ils
viennent tout droit d'un producteur de
mantes-la-jolie avec le pont cette année
la vente s'est répandu sur toute la
semaine ici on prévoit même d'en vendre
encore la semaine prochaine et
aujourd'hui on vend beaucoup d'autres
plantes aussi le présentait n'est plus
la plante principal pour la toussaint
vous avez des hellébores donc les
hellébores c'est ce qu'on appelle la
rose de noël et en fin de compte c'est
une plante qui va tenir tout l'hiver qui
gèle pas donc aujourd'hui les gens sont
plus intéressés justement sur des
plantes qui n'ont pas gelez qui vont
fleurir tout l'hiver si d'autres blancs
tout aussi robuste se vendent aussi
comme les bruyères ou des petites
jardinières composé spécialement pour
l'occasion
les chrysanthèmes reste les plantes les
plus traditionnels
quant au choix de la couleur il est lui
très personnelle de couleur jaune aux
couleurs claires certains quand ma
compagne étaient tous vivante cd seule
fleur qu'elle aimait donc l'homme a
disparu bas tous les ans je le fais pas
pour soutenir pour généraux d'après
l'interprofession des horticulteurs et
fleuristes 72% des plantes achetées pour
la toussaint en 2018 étaient des
chrysanthèmes avant d'accueillir -
prochaine invitée on parle tout de suite
sport dans ce journal
[Musique]
et ce soir c'est avec vous mais les
nippes hockey bonsoir comme ça de la
rédaction tv soixante dix huit ans ce
long week-end de la toussaint le sport
n'a pas fait comme nous on n'a pas pris
de repos avec pour commencer on parle
d'une défaite celle des handballeuses de
montigny le bretonneux c'est en
nationale 2 et c'est même la première
défaite de la saison pour les joueuses
de bras il s'agit alors jusqu'à présent
les énigmes antenne mener la danse
quatre matches quatre victoires mais ce
week-end face aux roses en elles n'ont
rien pu faire
elles ont mené six minutes en première
mi temps mais très vite les bretonnes
ont pris le dessus
score à la mi temps 7 à 12 en faveur des
visiteuses et s'il ya eu du mieux en
deuxième période les yvelinoises n'ont
jamais pu revenir au score alors elles
s'inclinent 7 x 17 à 22 la gardienne et
le coach de l'équipe nous donne quelques
clés de cette défaite et ce sur quoi
elles vont travailler on communique pas
donc on les laissait vraiment venir
jouer jusqu'à 6 mètres chose qui nous a
fait défaut
les joueuses étaient un petit peu lourde
sur les jeux transition donc on attaque
on faisait pas ce qu'on se connaît a
demandé ter au départ en résultat donc
l'équipe adverse a pris confiance et
commencer à nous faire mal sur le jeu de
transition qui est très très rapide
l'efficacité au tiers sur tout et ne pas
mélanger la précipitation et la rapidité
qui sont deux éléments complètement
différent parce qu'on a à cause de la
précipitation on a perdu beaucoup de
ballons en attaque ce qui fait que vam
frustration qui s'enchaînent
bon un petit accroc pour l'instant mais
elles pourront se rattraper avec leur
prochain match le 9 novembre
montigny qui affronte ici paris alors
une déception aussi côté trappistes
c'est du football
la saison continue d'être compliqué pour
l'étoile sportive de trappes leurs
équipes seniors qui évoluent en
régionale 2 ne trouve toujours pas la
solution ce week end ils affrontaient
villemomble alors résultat du match 2 à
0 c'est leur cinquième défaite en six
journées de championnat l'équipe pointe
pour le moment à la 11e place de leur
poule
du côté du rugby par contre il en faut
aussi un des satisfactions avait là ni
pour les joueurs de l'union au rugby
centre et oui l'équipe continue ses
débuts prometteurs alors on rappelle un
petit peu elle est née de la fusion des
équipes seniors du sky rugby et de
montigny le bretonneux lors ce week-end
les joueurs ont signé leur troisième
victoire en cinq journées face à vie au
grand air de saint maur qui leur a donné
un peu de fil à retordre surtout en
deuxième mi temps mais ça passe pour lui
et ses scores 26 à 16 un nom du
capitaine c'est mérité on sait qu'on a
deux essais de part et d'autre c'est
mérité je pense que sur le sur le jeu on
mérite en tout cas derrière sur les
phases même devant dans le combat sur la
première mi temps on va s'y mettre de
l'avant c'est donc on a pris la position
du match très vite en première mi temps
mais en deuxième mi-temps on pousse si
on résume 15 mi temps ils mériteraient
de prendre le le prendre dessus soit
deuxième mi temps alors pour leur
prochain match iran contre la lanterne
rouge de leur poule de rugby au melun
combs senart ça se passera le 10
novembre à 15 heures mais c'est en seine
et marne
merci mélanie et c'est aussi vous que
l'on retrouve tout à l'heure aux
manettes du cetud sport ce soir ses
résultats mais pas que 1 a retrouvé
après ce journal sur tv 78 je reçois
présent mon deuxième invité sacha
bonsoir alors vous êtes coiffeur vous
exercer à saint germain
en laye et vous avez publié cet été cet
ouvrage brève de coiffeur 46 ans
d'anecdotes de souvenirs sur votre
métier
pourquoi avoir eu envie de coucher
justement ses souvenirs sur sur le
papier secret vais un peu par ci par là
quelques phrases et pour m'encourager à
le faire j'ai d'ailleurs appris beaucoup
de plaisir à l'écrire tout en me disant
c'est authentique et finalement ça sera
peut être une petite trace dans ce
métier qu'elle exerce avec passion
depuis plus de quarante six ans et puis
c'est amusant c'est sympathique donc
c'était facile à écrire parce que vous
écrivez oui parce que c'est monsieur
régulièrement en plongée un peu dans ma
mémoire puis on en entend tous les jours
donc c'est ce n'a jamais été fait dans
cet ordre là donc c'est c'est sans
prétention sur de petites phrases des
brèves des braves de coiffeur tout
simplement vous avez bien mais en
portant la passion pour durer quarante
six ans dans ce métier c'est ce qu'il
était c'est ce qui vous anime tous les
jours c'est la passion oui c'est la
passion comme au premier jour
on peut pas faire ce métier pleinement
si on n'a pas la passion et c'est une
passion qui vous est venue jeunes c'est
ça 14 ans je pouvais à peine
oui papa un appel comment a débuté votre
carrière le chômage et j'ai commencé
dans l'est dans les grands salons
parisiens et ma soeur était quoi ce raid
était coiffeuse et elle menait un jour
et j'ai tout de suite été séduit par par
cette ambiance cette atmosphère et je
prends du plaisir chaque jour on sait
pas chaque jour quand vous travaillez
on ne sait pas qui va s'installer au
fauteuil donc ces découvertes des c'est
toujours nouveau cc un renouveau
perpétuel et sur ses 40 saison quel
regard vous portez sur votre carrière
vous êtes fiers de votre carrière oya
c'est oui c'est parce que j'ai je fais
ce qui me plaît déjà et j'ai eu beaucoup
de satisfactions à exercer mon métier
sur et comment vous définiriez pour
parler de votre stylet ce que chaque
coiffeur à son style
oui moi je dis souvent que je suis un
coupeur de chute des cheveux plutôt qu'à
coiffeur mais c'est sans prétention j'ai
un coiffeur et un être particulier quand
même avoir du caractère faux
faut savoir écouter les gens vous à voir
entendre et ne pas répéter ça doit
rester une conversation entre nick
l'antenne coiffeur ça doit rester entre
le coiffeur et la cliente
un coiffeur et d'un acteur la récente de
coiffure est un théâtre
donc c'est justement sur votre vision de
ce rôle de coiffeur vous dites d'une
jolie coupe de feu qu'elle est une
oeuvre d'art dont la vie dure quatre
semaines et je les coupe de feu et une
oeuvre d'art dans la vie gear 4 à 5
semaines mais c'est totalement vrai
c'est une oeuvre éphémère donc un rôle
d'artiste mais aussi social on se confie
assez volontiers à son coiffeur on parle
avec une aide beaucoup beaucoup
on m'a raconté des choses on se confie
vaucois son coiffeur sur la confiance
pour coiffer les enfants les parents les
amis on entend des choses parfois
curieuses est ce que comme les médecins
il ya une déontologie est ce que vous
gardez du coup pour vous ce conte ce
qu'on vous dit
surtout surtout il ya des coiffeurs qui
cancanent c'est pas mon cas un coiffeur
à porte pour une femme un coiffeur est
aussi important qu'un médecin était très
important pour une femme un coiffeur est
forcément aussi en 46 ans imagine
beaucoup d'anecdotes
est-ce qu il ya d une ou deux peut-être
qui vous reviennent en tête des
anecdotes là plusieurs médias tous les
jours tous les jeux à des anecdotes tous
les jours donc c'est dans le livre et
c'est toujours très c'est assez
croustillant mais les anecdotes au moins
une pour donner envie du coup aux
lecteurs de vous découvrir comment une
de ces années là j'ai une petite fille
qui m'a dit quand je vais couper les
cheveux
est-ce que les cheveux pleure quand tu
les coupes
alors quoi répondre alors j'ai fait un
rapport un peu
opi japon où j'ai dit vraisemblablement
mais c'est pour mieux les faire
repousser mon enfant alors l'objectif
maintenant vous lui disiez tout à
l'heure c'est de laisser une petite
trace sur voilà sur 7 46 ans 46 ans de
carrière alors il y en aura d'autres
encore mais peut encore c'est s'est
laissé une trace ni et puis ça les
coiffeurs sont intrigués par ce petit
livre et puis moi je continue ma
carrière toute façon mais ça m'a fait
plaisir d'écrire ça et je suis assez
fier de ça est ce qu'il ya des dates de
dédicaces prévue prochainement
je passais des prétentions m'a demandé
des choses mais je n'ai pas fait ça pour
être dans la lumière
ça ne m'intéresse pas merci d'être passé
en plateau pour parler de ce livre sa
charge je rappelle bref de coiffeur cod
aussitôt édition pardon les trois
colonnes au prix à 2 11 euros vous les
informations à qui s'affiche en bas de
l'écran
avant de vous laisser il a signé de
nombreuses oeuvres à saint quentin en
yvelines le sculpteur denis amandine
s'est éteint à l'âge de 77 ans parmi ses
réalisations les plus connus localement
un intérieur à l'extérieur cette famille
de géants vous avez forcément croisés
installé rue le nôtre à
montigny-le-bretonneux tout près du
centre commercial espace cinquante ans
une oeuvre en terre cuite rénové l'an
passé est installé pour la première fois
en 1999
écoutez ce que disait l'artiste à
l'époque dominique alba avant le boulot
ça leur fera plaisir de le retrouver un
peu chez eux ou dans un intérieur un peu
de miel l'idée était très simple et puis
je suis partie de là pour continuer la
démarche est plus une décoration plutôt
qu'une
une sculpture à une expression
personnelle de quelque chose j'ai fait
exprès de mettre plein de choses pour
qui est toujours un petit truc à
découvrir de sa dure assez longtemps
il ya beaucoup de gens qui m'ont c'est
la réflexion à mais j'ai pas lu ce
bouquin est ce que c'est celle tient le
plus longtemps possible dominique
toujours éphémère c'est pas des choses
pour l'éternité
mais les obsèques de denis à mondino se
sont tenues aujourd'hui à hatay fontaine
dans l'aisne
voilà c'est la fin de ce journal merci
de l'avoir suivi on se retrouve dès
demain pour une nouvelle édition
d'actualité locale en direct belle
soirée sur tv 78
[Musique]
non